opcw's definition of peace clearly we
have a limit mandate we are focused on
elimination of chemical weapons and
prevention of their emergence but also
we are focused on the promotion of
peaceful use of chemistry and and in the
coming years once we will make further
progress on the destruction of chemical
weapons we intend to focus more on
education and outreach we want to
address to university students we want
to address to high school students we
want to sensitize and raise awareness
among them about the risks of using
chemistry of course chemistry is has
always been in service of the humanity
and they have been many inventions which
you know served our interest but there
are also some risks so they should be
aware of those risks and we want to
cooperate with them in the future there
will be some seminars conferences
workshops and we want to use also we are
using more the social media network
tools we have we are on Facebook Twitter
and I would really encourage in fact the
youth the high school students as well
as university students to go on our
website and to have better understand
what we are doing and also how we are
serving the piece at the global peace
through our contributions in environment
and non-proliferation and in fact so
that they can share also their toes so
in relation to our activities